Elixir a dynamic general purpose
programming language designed to build
scalable concurrent applications with a
beautiful functional syntax it was
created by Jose velim and first released
in 2012 and today it consistently ranks
among the most loved programming
languages it runs on top of the erlang
beam virtual machine which itself is
developed in the 1980s to scale the
massive demands of phone switching which
it did with extreme reliability and bolt
tolerance Elixir was created to make
this powerful technology accessible to
the modern developer it's dynamically
typed with a minimal ruby-inspired
syntax making it more approachable than
statically type functional languages
like Haskell however because it's
compiled to beam by code it delivers
better performance and scalability
compared to interpreted languages it's
used by companies like Discord to handle
massive amounts of concurrent users by
Motorola to build fault tolerant
communication systems by Pinterest to
scale up their real-time notification
system and The Elixir based Phoenix
framework is responsible for thousands
of full stack web applications to get
started install erlang Andy Lex mixer
then create a file ending in dot EXs to
create a variable give it a name
followed by a value it's Dynamic so no
type annotations are necessary now print
it to the standard output with i o puts
and like Ruby parentheses are usually
optional alternatively you might create
an atom which is a constant whose value
is its own name Anonymous functions can
be created with the FN keyword which can
then be assigned to variables or passed
around to other functions and you can
even simplify this expression further
using the Ampersand shorthand when
working with function Expressions you
can use the pipe operator to pass the
value of one expression to another
without the need for a deeply nested
function calls create a list of items
with brackets or create a map to
represent key value pairs the equal sign
can be used to assign variables but it's
actually called the match operator to
support pattern matching features for
example we might destructure a list into
a set of variables if a pattern doesn't
match it will raise an error and this
Behavior can be used to implement
Advanced control flow logic if and its
inverse and less can be used for basic
situations but the case keyword allow
allows us to compare a value against
many patterns until we find a matching
one application code can be organized
and shared with modules inside a module
we can Define multiple functions but one
of the killer features of this language
is its concurrency model thanks to the
erlang VM all code runs in processes
that are isolated from each other which
communicate by passing messages they are
extremely lightweight and your
application can run thousands of them
simultaneously resulting in high
performance fault tolerant execution
this has been elixir in 100 seconds if
you want to see more short videos like
this hit the like button and subscribe
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one